for more on what might be next in the
investigation let's turn to CBS News
justice reporter Paula Reid she's in our
Washington bureau Paula good morning
good morning
follow what are we where are we here do
you think given given this news well
this is certainly not going to be the
culmination of the special counsels
investigation but there is a sense of
urgency here I mean filing an indictment
on a Friday late late in the week and it
seems that the earliest we're probably
going to hear a name or specific charges
will likely be Monday aims could
certainly leak over the weekend but it's
more likely that when the courthouse
opens on Monday that'll sort of start
the clock ticking on when we find out
who was charged and what they were
charged with Paula in terms of the
president's tweet what are we to make of
that you never know what to make exactly
of the president's tweets but he has
repeatedly tried to undermine this in
this investigation through use of his
Twitter account I don't know if you can
really sort of read into whether or not
he knew anything about what was going on
with a grand jury based on that tweet so
Paula I mean you heard Errol Barnett
mentioned Paul Manafort Michael Flynn
those are the two names that have been
then gone around the most here is I've
heard people suggest that the the first
indictments may ultimately be aimed at
at flipping a possible witness in this
case absolutely again the grand jury is
such a powerful tool for prosecutors
they do this in secret they can sort of
test their case determine whether or not
they have enough evidence to bring
charges but again it's a really low bar
it's probable cause we're not deciding
guilt or innocence here and nothing will
make a witness want to cooperate more
than knowing there's a sealed indictment
with his or her name on it sitting in a
courthouse somewhere Paula what what is
the timeline for the completion of the
Muller investigation do we have any
indication that because the first
indictments are coming down now that it
may be in fact complete by the end of
the year I think that would be a very
aggressive timeline to think that this
would be done by the end of the year I'm
speaking to sources who have been
involved in this investigation there's a
long timeline investigations like this
take a really long time because remember
not only do you have the Russia
conspiracy collusion aspect of this you
also have Mike Flynn's lobbying payments
to Turkey Paul manna for its business
dealings in the Ukraine the outstanding
question of obstruction of justice
you never know once you start turning
over rocks
an investigation like this where it
could leave so to think that it would be
done by the end of the year that just
does not seem realistic Paula Reid in
Washington thanks Paula